Obamacare is not as one judge said a
national solution to a problem it's
2,000 pages again of special interest
written law hi I'm Nicolas be with
recent TV and today we're talking with
James vida long he's a long time
Washington hand a lawyer and a long time
reason contributing editor Jim is the
author of ending big sis the special
interest state and renewing the American
Republic Jim thanks for talking to us
well thank you for having me I
appreciate it you said that the special
interest state which is what we have now
or what we're living under the grip of
you say its essence is that various
interest groups seized control over
power centers in government and use them
to advance their own ends talk a little
bit about the special interest state big
sis and where did it come from we often
talked about having a welfare state as
if we'd all gotten together and decided
that some people were worthy or some
causes were worthy of subsidy and
there's some of that in there but mostly
what has happened is as government has
grown it's gotten into this cycle where
the power becomes increasingly
fragmented into congressional committees
you know regulatory agencies prosecutors
offices all sorts of things and people
who can capture any of those sort of
positions can then use it for their own
purposes so instead of its it's not like
we as a society you know we go to the
polls we elect our legislators and then
they go and they say okay you know what
these people need help we're going to
give them this money or that it's rather
than there's all these different pockets
of power yes give money or regulatory
control where did the special interest
state come from I mean you talk about
how the intellectual muscle kind of
comes from the progressive movement but
then it's shifted into something else
it's a long history through the 19th
century the idea that laws should be for
the general welfare not for specific
class interests was part of the
political culture and very much part of
the legal culture you know I put a in
the book one of the biggest issues with
the railroads in the what railroads want
to do is reduce the farmers to peasants
and what the prot the farmers want to do
sort of make the railroads into a public
utility and the farmers get all the
money and so there was no easy way to
work out relations like that and they
were groping for it and so they kept
inventing new forms and then those kind
of mutate into special interest very
much those mutated into special
interests and various interest would
capture the agencies they got practice
and then you know you got the steady
increase in this through the New Deal
the New Deal was mostly a special
interest capture of chunks of the
federal though it's it's always talked
about as oh you know we were saving the
poor the hungry the naked but in fact it
was more I mean most of the signature
legislation was things to designed to
keep prices up yes rather than down so
that yeah right cartels in the book you
talk about this the special interest
state as a really is a crisis of
legitimacy the book does get into these
themes sometimes perhaps in more detail
than people would like political
legitimacy is one of the most important
concepts in politics I don't think many
people really regard dodd-frank as a
legitimate law its twenty two hundred
pages all written by various special
interest representatives who then
delegate everything to the Fed where
they will then fight it out again
Obamacare is not as one judge says a
national solution to a problem it's
2,000 pages again of special interest
written law you know like the pharma
carve out that you that's been in the
news recently so that's a pharmaceutical
companies are actually i'm going to do
quite well by this well yes explain
their belated support of the bill what
are the solutions to the special
interesting because in the book or i
mean you talked about possibly the rise
of a third party that would will heart
of an alternative to the democrats and
republicans who would say going back to
a national interest legislature is the
solution well maybe I think limited
government power limiting government
power is really the key in that you know
we tried this idea that if we expand
government power we will be ruled by
disinterested mandarins and I was part
of that crew when I was in the budget
Bureau a long time ago and it didn't
work and increasingly it seems to me the
founders under
stood the crucial thing about
controlling factions was that if they
gain control they couldn't do much you
know that you had all sorts of
limitations what are you know are there
are there bright spots are the green
shoots i hate yes praise of where where
power has been limited that i can't tell
you but i think the green issue does the
tea parties but in fact the book is
dedicated to citizen activists
everywhere because one of the great
supporters the special interest state is
the people are rationally ignorant most
of the time you know who follows this
stuff you can't understand the resource
conservation and Recovery Act and all of
that and why should you and so that
leaves this space where the special
interests who are very knowledgeable can
go in and loot and pillage and it seems
to me as people are increasingly upset
about this they increasingly realize
that they need to do something and they
become you know Raph ignorance becomes
less rational so it's kind of like
calling a truce of saying you know
rather than trying to win this kind of
race you know saying okay you know what
I'm going to you know we're just going
to stop playing well you know that use
what a constitution is and that is if
you look at the one of the best examples
is the First Amendment in that everyone
might prefer that his or her own
religion became the established religion
but everyone understands that if
everyone tries for this the result is
going to be rather unpleasant as Europe
learned in the 17th century so we all
agree we will not establish any religion
and then we all enforce that bargain and
that works very well once you have
mechanisms enforcement we've totally
lost that ethos in connection with
economic issues well thank you Jim
DeLong author of ending big sis the
special interest state and renewing the
American Republic reason contributing
editor lawyer Jim's long thanks very
much thank you for reason TV i'm nick
gillespie
you